[موسيقى]
آنو لؤلؤة الألم مع صعوبة القيام به
اتبع كيو
أمامي أوشيما آيس فورم أرز مقلي رودوس تيميتو باتيك فيليب
متصفح
الاسم أكيهو هادا
إنها ثقافة الطعام التي ابتكرها أجدادنا.
لا يوجد سيكاد أريد أن أرثه
لها تاريخ طويل جدًا ولا تحتاج إلى الماء
سمعت أنه إذا قمت بتوفير المال الذي ينمو بإصرار شديد ، فسوف يأتي بعد أن جاء السم.
ليأتي
لقد مررت بتجارب مختلفة ، وتم تجميع الأفضل.
ما يسمى
شكل جديد من الحبال
قف في الغرفة
العملية الميدانية والعرض تدفع نوع فيزياء السموم
[موسيقى]
لقد وضعت قطعًا فقط الآن ، لكن هناك ملفات تعريف الارتباط
ما كان ذلك في وقت سابق
من الغريب أن يكون لديك كاستيلا ، لكن موتشي يخرج من الآن فصاعدًا.
[موسيقى]
إيه
في هذه القرية ، كل الرمال الحديدية ميكيتي وشينتو ، أليس كذلك؟
إنه لذيذ ، أنا متأكد من أنه ليس لذيذًا.
سأبدأ في إبراز المستوى
عندما تحصل عليها ، خذ الخطيئة خطوة واحدة في كل مرة ، وخذ كل العناصر الحمراء ، ثم قسّمها إلى اليمين والمدرسة المحترمة والشمس
جاف
[موسيقى]
ضعها في رأسك
من 1 أسبوع إلى 10 أيام بعد القص أثناء مشاهدة الظهور حتى نهاية نادي رجال الإمبراطور العظيم
يمكنك معرفة ما إذا كانت هذه هي المرة الأولى.
إنه نصب Sindae of Goguryo التذكاري. إنه لذيذ أكل الناس.
الدرجة العلمية
لهذا السبب ، حتى لو قمت بنقلها ، فهي مواجهة سيئة تبرز في البحث ككل
بعد كل هذا
لأن عندي بيت يا أهل عمامي
أليس كذلك؟
[موسيقى]
مؤسسة Ichijoji مرتبطة بألوان سكان الجزر
إنها Shukun-sho
[موسيقى]
لذا فإن الطعام الذي يصنعه الأشخاص اللطفاء ، الجميع
أستطيع أن أعطيها لك
دهان
خذ هذا إلى الجميع ، أعط التعليمات ، أعلاه
عندما يختفي هذا إلى حد ما ، قم بتجديده فقط ، وتناول 50 منه وتذكره
أعني المنزل
عشت حياة
علاوة على ذلك ، هذا الشكل سام ، لذلك ليس من الجيد تناوله.
إنها حكمة الحياة ، أليس كذلك؟
قبل كل شيء ، خدم سكان الجزيرة
يجب الثناء عليها و الثناء عليها
أعتقد أنه نبات
[موسيقى]
أعتبرها ثقافة ، لذلك أعتز بها.
اريد ان اجذب الثقافات
هذا أيضًا يجعل محطتي تستحق العيش.
[موسيقى]